voilà c'est très propre
bonjour vous arrivé juste à temps pour
ma conférence
ouais comment vous ne savez pas ce
qu'est une conférence
et bien c'est c'est une sorte de
discours sur un sujet très intéressant
et ce sujet aujourd'hui ce sera moi
voilà installé vous la conférence
commence dans quelques minutes sur sa
faites attention vous allez défonce
évoqué testera les six élus merci
beaucoup à la solidarité d'une chose
merveilleuse le spa c'est toujours
ébahis de voir une personne se porter au
secours d'une autre personne c'est beau
d'espoir mais c'est très bien ça dit
avec vous pourriez peut-être
l'explication
après que nous ayons posée était un
objet ou roulent elle-même au pardon
pardonnez ma distraction à ses amis je
veux poser ici la voix doucement attend
attention aux doigts puissent savoir ce
que cous vous comptez faire avec cette
recette est rappelé c'est une estrade
maire je profitais cette belle journée
pour faire une grande conférence à une
conférence est formidable et quel en
sera le sujet la vie extraordinaire de
fulbert du snop une conférence sur vous
même oui trouvez vous un sujet plus
intéressant peut-être mais enfin après
tout c'est vous qui est le maître du
choix de votre sujet branchez approcher
tous art
la conférence a commencé mais mais que
se passe-t-il
casimir installez vous tous pour la
conférence un but que l'otan vous avez
entendu il m'a volé mon idée aussi
monsieur l'étang de cet extra
d'immédiatement et pourquoi monsieur que
ma grande conférence a commencé dans un
instant monsieur vous ferez votre
conférence si vous voulez mais après la
non je regrette mais la conférence de la
forêt avant non monsieur
que se passe-t-il
mais tu vois toi blâme casimir à
monsieur du snap se disputent une fois
de plus julie à quel sujet bizone par
hasard tous les deux l'idée de faire une
conférence et aucun ne veut parler après
l'autre vert rouge et ça c'est un
spectacle vraiment grotesque
vous allez arrêter tous les deux ans de
celui qui publie ce qui vous arrive et
vous perdu toute dignité
monsieur du sna peut faire une
conférence avant noir et sur quel sujet
bon j'en sais rien du tout j'ai
certainement plus intéressant que que la
tienne parce que vous connaissez le
sujet sur lequel veut parler kazimi non
mais c'est un peu trop collant intérêts
de toute façon on mettrait bien les gars
arrêtez de les arrêter
c'est moi qui vais décider celui qui
parlera en premier voilà au hamois et
comment allez-vous faire ambitieux c'est
tout simple c'est tout ça que je vais
prendre celui qui aura le sujet le plus
intéressant alors j'ai gagné sans aucun
doute je suis le vainqueur
pas si vite tous les deux casimir quel
est le sujet de la conférence sur le
sujet le plus intéressant il soit c'est
à dire moi à et vous monsieur des snobs
un sujet merveilleux moi même c'est tout
non monsieur n'intéresse personne
françois rien ne vous intéresse alors
rien de t'intéresser je me suis mais en
tout cas pas vos conférences à tous les
deux alors
alors eh bien je vais chanter une
chanson à bombay qui aura pour sujet
commander mais vous n'aviez pas deviner
mais sûrement nous voyons au françois
[Musique]
créée
c'est ce que je voudrais vous
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
outre m
être les fourmis les souris ont des vies
extraordinaires
je
mais explique ses mystères je voudrais
être très savants que d'être le secret
des choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants wasquehal kate il deviner ce
qu'on trouve au delà des étoiles il voit
ton parfois des lions d
hier les moineaux les corbeaux et les
marches tout vrai
les canaux
[Musique]
là
les dauphins l'est parce qu'ils sont de
vrais m
[Musique]
son
c'est
curieux comme des poissons dans la mer
je voudrais être très savants connaître
le secret des choses et il y at-il
vraiment quelque part des éléphants
russe quelqu'un est une deviner ce qu'on
trouve au delà des épaules ils voient
trompa repas des lions des hommes des
cigales
très
c'est ce que je voudrais
[Musique]
c'est
à